der horst otto n tv
deutschland bekommt die
europameisterschaft 2024 wird
deutschland damit zum nächsten mal nach
2006 ein ganz großes fußballturnier
ausgetragen zum ersten mal seit 1988 die
europameisterschaft 24 mannschaften
werden nach deutschland kommen die wahl
war sehr eindeutig 12 24
für den dfb gegen die türkische fußball
föderation die exekutive der uefa war da
sehr entschieden für die organisation
bedeutet das erst mal dass philipp lahm
eine große rolle bekommen wird in der
organisation des turniers in der
vorbereitung des turniers wird
er wird quasi der cheforganisator sein
wollen gemeinsam ein riesen großes fest
feiern
bei uns in deutschland und wir sind sehr
gastfreundlich und offen und das wollen
wir 20 24 auch wieder zeigen und es
bedeutet
desweiteren eigentlich für den für den
deutschen fussball oder für den
profifußball einen schub liga präsident
rauball sprach jeder von dass ein großes
turnier in deutschland der liga immer
etwas gebracht hat die liga hat auch
sehr gehofft dass das der dfb diesen
zuschlag bekommt weil man sich schon im
hintertreffen sieht insbesondere
gegenüber england aber man auch angst
hat dass man gegenüber spanien und
italien beispielsweise zurück fällt also
insofern ist es ein ist das ein starker
schub für die liga es wird in zehn
stadien gespielt werden
das sind im grunde genommen die
bekannten stadien von der
weltmeisterschaft 2006 also es wird
jetzt kein stadion neu gebaut werden für
diese em das finale soll wieder in
berlin stattfinden sowie das 2006
aufwarten und 288 war es damals noch das
olympiastadion von münchen
die türkischen bewerber sind zum vierten
mal mit einer bewerbung hier bei der
uefa gescheitert dass da natürlich die
stimmung nicht gut war ist klar der
türkische sportminister war hier äußerte
sich sehr enttäuscht zumal ja auch die
eindeutigkeit des ergebnisses belegt
dass die usa offenbar tatsächlich kein
vertrauen in diese türkische bewerbung
hatte was vermutlich sehr viel weniger
damit zusammenhängen dass das dass man
der türkei grundsätzlich nicht zutraut
eine em auszutragen sondern tatsächlich
mit der wirtschaftspolitik der regierung
erdogan mit dem lehrer verfall und und
der unsicherheit die die wirtschaft in
der türkei der zeitung geht
[Applaus]